the late Queen Elizabeth II passionate
about the Commonwealth for her whole
reign we must all try to cultivate the
virtues of Tolerance and understanding
but for a modern day King it's an
inheritance that could present a threat
to the monarchy itself no matter what he
might say the Commonwealth can play an
indispensable role in the most pressing
issues of our time
one thing King Charles doesn't inherit
from his mother's passing is her Global
popularity and critics are asking why
should Britain's monarchy preside over a
post-colonial institution when
imperialism of the past costs lives and
enslaved so many people
however the Commonwealth brings Nations
and cultures together enabling better
trade and cooperation there are shared
goals of peace and democracy
Global opinion is divided the sources
and experience of colonialism has been
one of systematic and structural
violence and plunder and brutality I
really like King Charles I think he's
earned his place to be king and I think
he's going to do a great job the size of
the Commonwealth is staggering more than
2.6 billion people 56 countries around a
third of the world's population
Australia India parts of Africa colonies
once ruled by Britain up here dwarf by
Canada the largest land mass of all
Canada and 14 other nations have King
Charles as their head of state but
descent is increasing particularly in
the Caribbean countries of Antigua and
Barbuda Belize and Jamaica
anti-monarchy demonstrations in the
Caribbean last year disrupted the
schedule for a royal Tour by The Prince
and Princess of Wales and this sentiment
is growing these are our jurisdictions
in which there are significant appeals
for reparations at least for some direct
acknowledgment of the historical uh
Injustice suffered by these places and
also the ways in which that historical
Injustice shapes contemporary uh
inequality the ability to make some kind
of acknowledgment of
um past crimes is distinct from the
decision to spend current and future
resources towards reparation
Republican campaigners in 12
commonwealth countries are marking the
coronation of King Charles this weekend
with a formal letter demanding an
official apology and reparations for
past actions Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera
the Australian prime minister says that